hi I'm Jason Harris I work in the front
end and I'm talking today about the
template boxes advanced notations
typesetting and how you can create your
own notations to facilitate your your
notations and the fields of study or
work that you work in and implement
those in Mathematica in the same way
that we do internally so in this talking
workshop we're going to detail some of
the advanced typesetting capabilities in
Mathematica we're going to explore ways
in which you can create your own typeset
notations which are particular to your
field of study or practices Stephan
talked about last night we're very
interested in computational essays and
being able to express things
computationally in Mathematica and of
course we want to be able to extend
Mathematica in certain ways and this is
what we'll have a tour through a lot of
the capabilities of the underlying bits
of the front end and the and how that
talks to the kernel through this through
this talk and workshop ok so we're going
to cover how the front end represents
things and how it actually talks to the
kernel through this make boxes and make
expression here and so we're going to
discuss of course style sheets which are
involved with template boxes and how to
package up here are notations and
interspersed with this we're going to
talk about some of the new features that
that of and we have added to Mathematica
over the last we well ok so the first
bit of this talk we're gonna talk about
how the front end actually represents
things internally and it does so by
boxes and so we're gonna talk about
those then we're going to talk about
make boxes and make expression and how
the typesetting system talks between the
front end and the kernel and how we can
influence that and and and change how it
interprets things then we'll move on to
template boxes these sort of modern
structures which is sort of taken over a
lot of the internal typesetting in
Mathematica we'll talk about style
sheets how to package these things up
talk about some enhancements for
template boxes and finally we'll round
out some stuff with the notation package
and how to shortcut a lot of the work
that we'll see as we as we start
developing stuff and examples so okay
let's start with our simple goals so in
Mathematica of course we can enter some
partial derivative of the acts of you
know X cubed and and that works and
that's fine that's great Mathematica
knows how to do that in fact I'll just
quit my kernel here which I should have
done before just start off with a nice
fresh version of Mathematica pristine so
you know I've got nothing up my sleeve
so Mathematica can turn around and
decide to connect maybe to the network
which is having problems with
fun
yeah that's a nice clean start to the
the whole thing okay so our goal of
course and and watching this go I'm
using our own development version there
there we go whoo that took a long time
to try and connect um so it found the
derivative and record slow time and so
our goal here is if given given that
Mathematica doesn't understand this
partial plus so it understands of course
parcel X but not for instance partial
plus and of course the mathematical
sciences are big there's many notations
out there and our goal is to be able to
work in the notations that would like
and so we need to be able to extend
Mathematica some notations out there
conflicts um some ways we represent
things possibly are not built into
Mathematica and we'd like to be able to
add them so that's our goal sure you
didn't get an input so I'm not sure what
you did try to get them so it's okay so
everything in Mathematica is actually
boxes so if we if we turn around and we
enter some you know expression as we'd
normally do through the normal editor
that's actually represented internally
in the front end by boxes and so you can
use this show expressions thing this
this menu option the accelerators
command shift e or shortcut control
shift e on windows and if we select that
we actually see what the internal
representation of the structure is and
so this X cubed here is represented by
this superscript box and of course
there's this grouping along with the
plus and the two inside a row box and
further to this if we take a look at
this particular example just a normal
sort of integral and we take a look at
it well we see here this is an integral
it's got the integral character it's got
an infinity it's a sub superscript box
to get from zero to infinity it has an
exponential e here superscript box power
and so on and in fact in this structure
we could go in and actually change that
to a
tea for instance in inside the actual
boxes and as we see it's changed it on
the outside that will have the exact
same effect as if we'd done it through
the normal editor in Mathematica and so
of course these if my process is not
heinous ly slow Wow
how am I making it full form to get that
form I hit command shift e like this and
so that's right under Selva so menu
command shifting and so of course this
these both evaluate to a conditional
expression we can evaluate that and of
course it works just as one would expect
okay so let's take a look at this in a
little bit more detail here we've got
this input field it's got a dynamic for
the that that's that changes
continuously in terms of and it
expresses it sets that the boxes in
terms of boxes as this continuous action
goes to true and so here what we can do
is we can enter something like a plus B
and we actually see the expression that
the front end has internally right here
as we type stuff and so if we type a
plus B times C for instance we actually
see that internally the front end has
gripped this structure nicely and it's
parsed it and so that's the parser going
on inside the front end and so that's my
job along with some of the other people
is but you know I typed some particular
integral 0 you see this is a subscript
box and if I had typed the other I get
some superscript box you know of e to
the you know minus X you know ask a
differential D X and so you can see all
these boxes appear and disappear as we
type stuff and so that's the front end
parser representing the internals of
Mathematica so it's about boxes
underneath and you might say well okay
that's fine for typeset Nast but what
about graphics graphics is surely
something different but it isn't a
graphics here is actually a graphics box
with a line box all these various line
boxes and you might say well that's
simple for simple points and lines but
what about something complicated like a
daisy a curve well a basic curve is
actually underneath a Bezier curve box
and so all graphics tubes 3d stuff weird
stuff it's all boxes and in fact you
might say well what about styling
elements you know that's really
something different but no a style is
actually a style box you might say
controls are different they're controls
as you type them in and to math Anika
and use them that must be some UI thing
but in fact a button is actually a
button box underneath and here we have a
slider that's connected to a dynamic
here and as I move that you know the
slider changes the value of MN and it
changes there and of course a slider is
represented by a slider box and a
dynamic is represented by a dynamic box
so it's all about boxes everything and
the front-end internally basically is
all about boxes there's some cells that
wrap it in notebooks that wrap those and
yep there's yeah so the list plot yeah
almost a lot and know if my
documentation is cooperating we take a
look at that command shift E and you see
there's a graphics box of RGB box the
absolute thickness is blah blah blah and
they're all boxes gridlines and you know
so on and and various options and but it
is still box right so so of course so we
go back to our goal now so now that you
know that the internal representation of
everything in the front end is actually
boxes what was our goal our goal was to
be able to Mathematica to be able to
handle computations and new things
things that aren't previously defined so
what's going on how do we so generators
we can't just use those they're you know
just like style or button they're
they're not sufficient so what is the
actual evaluation model of what's going
on in Mathematica so what happens as we
start with the box structure as we see
on screen it get sparse
through make expression to a new kernel
expression it happens through evaluation
gets a new kernel expression and then it
gets formatted to a new box structure so
let's let's see this sort of in action
here so if I evaluate this as I see it
in the front end partial derivative of Y
if sign Y over 2 it gives us cosine Y
every two very clear derivative sine is
cosine what's what's sort of going on
here so what happens is we start out
with a box structure which box structure
well the box structure that's rendered
as partial Y sine Y over 2 and that's
internally represented in the front end
as this you know row box the subscript
of subscript bucks here partial d the y
the fraction box and sine Y and blah
blah blah okay and so that actually gets
parsed through make expression and sent
off to the kernel to get this new
expression as you'd normally type into a
terminal D sine Y over 2 that gets
evaluated in the kernel to a new
expression here cosine Y evertune
derivative of sine is cosine that will
then get sent to the front end as
formatted in two boxes and it'll be sent
to these boxes a fraction box of row box
of cosine Y over 2 and that looks like
in the front end cosine Y over 2 and
that's how we perceive the evaluation to
occur and in fact we can take a look at
this if we go here to the notebooks
kernel take a look at link Snooper go
here and just evaluate this again and
there and I'll grab these this
expression here paste it in here blow
that up and we can actually see right up
the top and this enter expression the
the front end is sending off to the
kernel here this make expression of this
various things
here's encoding of the partial D in some
weird encoding and this fraction box and
so on and then the kernel right here
will be sending back the made boxes to
the front end so that's what's happening
there and so you can sort of see this
communication let's go back and actually
quit link Snooper here and go back and
check change my kernel to local okay so
you can take a look at make boxes and
make expression so these are the things
these make expression here that
the parsing right here and we take boxes
and the box has become an expression so
it's making expression and we have the
formatting it takes an expression and
gives us boxes and so that's make boxes
so let's do our first example here of
partial plus this was the example we had
PD plus of X with respect to PD pluses
plus of X right now that doesn't
actually work in Mathematica so what we
need to do is we need to add some for
parsing rules that will actually let
that actually work and so what we're
gonna do is we're gonna say make
expression of some boxes well which
boxes so we we unform at the cell there
we grab the boxes like so and in
standard form we can confirm that
Mathematica right now it doesn't know
how to make those boxes so which boxes
will you like it to be well we want it
to be P deep we want it to in the end be
this expression PT plus that's going to
be our full form of this partial plus of
X and so if we take a look mathematic it
does know how to make those boxes so if
I say make expression of the boxes here
I'll grab these like so paste those in
and standard form and Mathematica does
know how to make those so what we can do
is we can simply tell me a thematic ax
how to make those boxes it doesn't know
in terms of these boxes it does know
it's so and now if I evaluate this right
here partial positive x I can actually
see mathematic is being able to
interpret it by defining this make
expression rule of the boxes it doesn't
know in terms of boxes it does know I
can now evaluate this in Mathematica can
now parse this weirdo notation it didn't
know before our first notation so that
that's good
but if I change that to partial plus of
T doesn't understand that because of
course this is X so I need to change
this to a variable X there and change
this to a variable and now this is a
general notation it works I've changed
it I can you know put that over to and
so on and it does what it's meant to so
that's grant so that works but that's
only half of it because now if I turn
around and have some expression pd+
so you know pd+ you know are here
something else it doesn't get formatted
and partial pluses and so we need a rule
to actually say this how this expression
should look like so make boxes of what
what thing are we going to do we're
going to have make boxes of this
expression and I've lost my completions
standard oh I'm gonna need my
completions I absolutely need my
collisions I'm sorry I'm just gonna
that's a maybe that bug here and what's
going on I'm gonna have to restart that
that's a version and that's in Toms code
not mine
so let's go here so back to here we've
got this first rule to make expression
rule that we've actually had and now we
want a rule for a make there we go make
boxes there we go and of what which
boxes we're gonna make a expression pd+
of something are in standard form is
going to be some set of boxes well which
boxes is it going to be it's going to be
our scape heat pd+ of X for instance and
so it's going to be those boxes I'll
just go here grab them and you note that
my trick is I'm entering the external
expression in Mathematica and then I get
the underlying boxes and that gives me
the structured boxes here and of course
I need an R here this needs to be
general for any R so I'll put this in
and so we think well that that's
probably going to work and so we get pd+
but it doesn't so it gives us this weird
cell context T thing which is going on
so that looks like we're taking make
boxes takes an expression it gives us
boxes but this expression here this R is
an expression so this is an expression
here and we've got boxes so this needs
to be further made right here to make
boxes of R comma stratiform
okay and now we'll see this work it'll
give us a right thing and it all works
so we've now got partial plus of you
know their plus you know T and so on and
it has the rightful forms and everything
works okay
so those are our rules for partial
pluses and now that we've added this
notation we can turn around and use it
and so we can say the simple rule
partial plus of the sum of things that
the sum of the partial pluses would just
define it works it's a full it's a full
notation in Mathematica and it gives us
the right answer and of course that has
the rightful form okay so the this this
trick is we it's best to create your
notations as you've seen I type them in
n to D and I get the underlying boxes
and I use those in my expressions so one
thing before I give you your first
example to actually sort of think about
if I enter in some expression P D plus
another trick that's kind of good so
I've entered in this and in a sort of
input form I can use this other option
here so convert to standard form command
shift N and it will actually go through
this make boxes and make expression for
standard form we defined all of these
rules kind of quickly here for standard
form these make boxes and make
expression rules and so here they've
been applied I can go back to input form
standard form input form standard form
and you actually see that this it's
actually using these rules and as we
define these rules it's quite important
that we obey the evaluation properties
and make sure we don't have any leakage
so in other words when I go back command
shift n kamancheh strongly command shift
and I'm not evaluating this 2+2 okay so
our first example here for you guys to
actually sort of think about so I know
that you don't have tables in front of
you we don't actually have the notebook
but it just sort of think about this
what how would we handle this so this is
a notation it's built into Mathematica
partially for function evaluation so
that's quite nice I can show that to the
average person like your average Java
programmer maybe and they'll understand
it whereas they won't understand this
okay
so with like of course this here when we
enter some some sort of function here
function of you know become a B cubed
for instance here we'd like that to
appear like this by default since Dan
and it appears like that in traditional
form if I hit command shift T to get to
a judicial forum it appears like that
but not in standard form how would I go
about doing this no idea so we're gonna
be using make boxes or make expression
right so we've got to do something so it
actually understands of course make
expression because it can parse this it
can it can understand this so it can go
from there to an expression function and
then it can evaluate it but the make box
is going from this expression that to a
different set of boxes is not defined so
we're gonna need a make expression rule
we're gonna be going from a make boxes
rule I should say we're gonna be going
from sure yep well so so so so Lu in
each i up the back and a few of the
other people have defined that they're
Mike and Patriots and this this endeavor
they've defined for a traditional form
yeah they've defined a lot of this these
sorts of notations and so they've
decided what does traditional form
looked like what does standard form look
like and so that put these rules in so
now it's up to you it's you want to bend
Mathematica to your will to actually
decide what you want to do and put them
in as you'd like and so this through
this talk then you're in the end got the
power to actually do this so we need to
make boxes rule here and we're gonna
make some expression into boxes and so
which is kind of things something else
like that which boxes well let's just go
here and grab these boxes and so as
before we grab these boxes here and so
of course well we don't want this just
it for B we want this for some general
variable called V maybe the function f
we don't know how to put this in as a V
and this thing here is in as an F okay
so that should actually work but it
won't and why would it work well of
course this is an expression that's an
expression these are all boxes so this
must needs to be a box as well so this
needs to be and thank boxes further
recursively call that in standard form
and the same way with the F right over
here
it is and I'm gonna do another one and
then another one another one so you
actually get it and say meow of course
this works as you'd expect and it now
parses in our functions now appear but
as standard like this throughout our
code and we can read it and we say
that's that's comprehensible and we like
that and in terms of the other okay yes
yes
well so that I'm building up the
reasoning to actually how we get so this
as they go through this talk will
actually use the notation package and
I'm so notation package actually works
by exactly doing this it's a transpiler
it will take your notation statements
and actually compile them or transpile
them generate code equivalent to this
and so you can actually sort of see it
so i'm explaining the internals and we
want to know that for this template box
sort of stuff coming up but good
question
so so let's take a look at another
example here up and down so we have you
know like maybe a spin glass in physics
or you know electrons with some spin or
something and some ket wear bra would
actually like to to represent and of
course mathematic it doesn't understand
this again and would like this to be
understood as up Ave so we have some
nice notation for for spins so sir first
of all since it doesn't understand it we
need to as before go back to our diagram
and take a look we need this parsing
step this make expression we've got a
box structure kernel can't understand it
so we need to be able to parse it so we
go back here and we're going to be an
egg expression here and make expression
and we're gonna make some boxes which
boxes will these boxes that Mathematica
doesn't understand sub superscript boxes
here and standard form and we're gonna
make that in terms of some boxes that it
does understand which are these boxes
here so this is going to be make make
expression of something come a standard
form right there in which boxes is it
going to have it's going to have these
boxes right here
and of course we need to make this
general so this needs to be a underscore
and this needs to be an a and now
Mathematica can actually parse our are
up and of course if we have up of a + up
of B we turn around and it's not it's
not formatting is there up we would like
it to look like this of course because
that's that's what we're used to in
physics or whatever field we're using it
and so we need now of course a make
boxes rule to take this expression here
today in standard form to a set of boxes
which boxes well these boxes and so here
it's going to be like that and of course
this here this a I won't show you that
well here again of course this is an
expression in here
this is boxes so this needs to be
further made by make boxes and standard
form right here okay and now our up of a
enough of B actually work they give us
the right form so we can turn around and
simply just get these rules where's this
do the other copy those get here and
change this to a down arrow down arrow
and change the sit down and likewise
down and likewise down arrow okay and
then we've got up and down so I can
enter in on my up + down of you know T
and now I can hit my command shift n
from before and I get my it gets the
formatting it uses these make expression
make boxes rules and it has of course
the correct full form and I've added
notations for my up and down okay oh
yeah sure
exactly and so so yes so our boxes when
we were making boxes we have an
expression here and so all of this all
of the side has to be boxes and of
course then we recursively further make
it so it's a little bit different
because our make expression statements
here there that we express we solve the
make expression by writing rewriting it
in terms of another make expression it
knows but make boxes internally we
actually write it to the actual final
answer so it's a little bit lopsided and
how it works you can make expression
give you the final result but you've got
a very careful about the holding
attributes as you go on and do stuff so
it's it's a bit tricky Rob you could use
a pattern form um yeah I I just
generally don't like my notations being
too wild and spilling over into other
things because if you go to the input
form or do something else that just I
don't know I've just used it usually
being a bit more targeted and specific
and but yes yeah I think you could
yep and so if I is the master that
actually uses these I'm the guy that
sort of designs the underlying bits to
make them work so the but but each I
will have listened to each I here so
okay so oh yeah sure
Cleo sure yep yep yep
well you need to not to be sure but to
need to yes yep sometimes integers
there's there some it's always yeah
always use make boxes because this this
here will be an expression and so if
it's an integer there we still needed
the string one to actually display so
sometimes the front end will fudge it
and say I think I know what you mean
it'll do it but quite often at one and
so you saw that cell context errors and
some of the other bits oh yes always use
make boxes okay so let's move on now now
that we've got this we've got our
underlying knowledge of what's going on
to template boxes so here let's take a
look at binomial here in traditional
form so value eight this we get a
binomial okay so I can evaluate that
binomial and I get binomial n comma K it
looks kind of nice I mouse over it I see
this this tooltip looks kind of good and
so now that you know that everything in
the front end has represented as boxes
you know there's going to be some boxes
underneath this and we're gonna have
like a bracket obviously a grid boxy
sort of thing in another bracket that's
what it's going to be like underneath
right and so if I now take a look at
this expression here community oh I
don't see that at all I see something
quite different I see this template box
here of two parameters n comma K and
binomial which doesn't look at all like
the the typeset form and in fact if I go
here to this binomial and I change this
to Bessel J for instance and
or Matt it it now looks like a decimal
function it evaluates like a Bessel
function it has a tool tip of a Bessel
function and if I change this for
instance rulers on the under P for
instance it it's a little under function
and it evaluates it looks like it and it
behaves like a like a like a Legendre
function and we're back to binomials
what's going on how does this magic
happen well let's let's let's let's look
at the following
so Royal boxes allows us to have some
box structure and look at it directly in
the output if I command shifting I see
these boxes here right here this
template box will be exactly like the
input so this is what the Royal boxes is
doing and so it gives us we've got some
arguments a comma W and foolish entre P
and now if I mouse over I see it
actually looks like foolish Ondra P with
this tooltip I evaluate that and I get
foolish Ondra P interesting so if I
change that to something like bar and
evaluate it I now get my tooltip being
bar and it evaluates is bar so what's
happening here is this tooltip being
automatic and will go and grab whatever
the name of that is the tag and wrap it
around these arguments that the tooltip
will be displayed as that name and for
evaluation that's coming in it gets that
name and it wraps it around those
arguments and we get the actual output
form so that's how it's being
interpreted but how is it being
displayed how does it know what to look
like well it uses this display function
here as an option to the the template
box and so this is just a normal pair
function but it returns boxes and so
which boxes if I apply this display
function to these arguments here it will
give us another box structure in that
box structure if we look at it in terms
of raw boxes will appear as our output
so what the display function does is it
tells the template box
hey wrap this around these arguments get
a new box structure and use that to
display the template box and it'll use
it'll it'll display it like so so that's
grant so so from there we have these
template boxes they're quite nice is we
can tab through them it gives us just
our particular arguments and we can
delete the various arguments here and
it'll delete the whole thing it looks it
looks
and then we can go back here to our
Foolish and repeat okay so we can now
formally state a little bit more of what
a template box actually is so a template
box is I need a pointer using a template
box is a collection of boxes and a tag
and what the display function will do is
it'll take the the tag and it'll wrap it
around sorry it'll take the display
function and wrap it around those boxes
to get a new box and it'll use that to
draw of what the template box should
look like so it's a parameterised box
structure it's a low-level parametrized
box structure and this display function
it's normally oh wow oh thanks so this
display function no and you how to drive
oh there we go so there's a slight
function right here is is normally
specified on the style sheet and it uses
the display function to visually show
what this template box will actually
look like and the tag of the template
box if it's a string it'll actually use
that style on the style sheet so I'll
talk about that in just a second here we
get to it so so here let's take a look
at in fact let's take a look at our
binomial example here so we go back here
we get some binomial grab that get a
couple binomials plus another binomial
here and become a K it has the right
interpretation and so on so how does it
know what to draw like well we can go
here we can go to the default style
sheet and then go to the core style
sheet and then actually search for
binomial well that's interesting isn't
it
fine Emil and go there grab that style
go back here paste it in here make this
big so you can actually sort of see it
and turn around and look at it and so
here when we do this we can actually see
the binomial stall itself has this this
template box options and a display
function goes to row box and now we can
actually see it we can see the
bracketing bar the grid box and the
other bracket and so if we want to
actually change what the binomial looks
like uniformly we can actually go and
give it a new notation so for instance
let's say C could be combination and
things taken at a time
and so we could go here get that and
we're going to use this is our new
display function so I grab those boxes I
go here this needs to be this display
function that's right
display function there needs to be a new
display function and we paste this in
it's got to be a sub superscript box
we'll use this as the first argument of
my template box and use this as the
second argument of my template box and
now first second there we go and so now
as I'm going to unform at that it'll now
change what the display function is and
so this since it's on its style sheet
will become the active and dominant
style of how the display function is
resolved for binomial and so these will
now change to this new notation so I'm
gonna change this in 3 and take a look
over here as you see it over those ones
there are three to one and it now change
of course all of the binomials
throughout this notebook to appear in
this new notation and of course they're
a nice template boxes I can go in delete
the whole things and you know it
evaluates to the right-right-right
structure and of course if i go back
here onto the style sheet and turn
around and delete that binomial here it
will turn back to the normal binomials
in terms of its formatting okay
so the style sheets as we can see now
are actually kind of important and in
fact they they'll have the display
functions for our various template boxes
on the the style sheet so let's take a
look at this in a little bit more detail
we have another example here we've got a
Mike commutator and it's display
function is from before it's got this
you know a row box with some brackets
here and so it looks like this so what
happens if we go there in and take out
its display function so no longer has
the display function well if it
evaluates it says it can't find it it
gives us this nice helpful error message
that template box was unable to use the
specified display function or it was
unable to locate the display function
possibly because the style sheet is
missing and of course it has no style
for my commutator so it can't style it
it doesn't know what to put it in it
right the the this Mike commutator
this thing here that's that the that
underneath is a template box and the
rendering of that template box is a
default error style which builds it up
from the various bits too it's it's it's
it's the template box if I go to manage
50 I see a template box and so the
template box rendering of that is when
it doesn't I can't resolve the display
function internally and the C code that
we write it goes then it goes I can't
got it I'm gonna display it like this
yep so I just I hit shift return and
it's got this default which I'll talk
about in just a second the the
interpretation function of what's going
on okay so what we want to do is we want
to get this style here of course that
works there we want to put this on the
style sheet so I wrote this package
which apparently is not part of passable
yet which I'll put on so inject styles
and so we can actually go in here and
inject this style on to the style sheet
we want to add it right here on the
style sheet somewhere down here so we go
here we inject styles on to where it's
going to be this input notebook and
which style are we gonna add we're going
to add this my commutator style and then
we're gonna add an options it will be
tool to that template box template box
Options and we're going to add a list of
options for it and which option are we
going to add or we're gonna add this
display function yes son and so now it
changed I did that a bit too quickly but
you saw this one right here it changed
should I do that again I'll go back here
to the style sheet remove it here from
the style sheet because it's edited
right there and do it again and
right here
they're my commutator and now I inject
it again you'll see this my commutator
it will change as the style goes on to
the style sheet there needs it needs a
bit of updating sometimes as it goes
okay
so we've now injected the styles onto
the style sheet
okay so as before now we'll go to my
commutator works we can turn around and
we want this my commutator of course to
appear like a commutator if I if I get
some of these here I add them together
you know 80 something else like that
we want these to actually appear as
commutator so we need these expressions
to appear as a different set of boxes
which boxes we want to be able to turn
around and make them make boxes make
boxes of some expression here a my
commutator of that and standard form is
going to be equal to which boxes well
these boxes here so let's just grab
those it's a template box
here and of course the same trick is
before we know this is a you know B this
has to be make boxes of a comma standard
form in the same way for the B here and
now of course if I enter this evaluate
it I now appear and we've got our
notation in terms of my commutator so by
defining the snake boxes rule just below
that I've just scrolled off screen we
now have our commutator and so one of
the other things you can actually do is
actually change this interpretation
function is one of the other things
right now this is being interpreted as
my commutator I can get this commutator
I can copy it hit the copy command copy
and then go off to an external program
and paste it here and it'll actually
copy as my commutator and it uses the
interpretation rule which is the default
one which just wraps the the head around
it but we could change that we could
turn around and say we want the
interpret interpretation function to be
some function here and which function do
we want it to be of some boxes well
let's call it like x commutator of and
we'll go becoming a just to just get it
around a different way just to show that
we can and so we we get these boxes for
the interpretation function so the
interpretation function we return a set
of boxes it should be evaluated as and
so we'll put this as argument to so in
other words we'll reverse the arguments
here argument 1 and now if I evaluate
that it'll actually evaluate as an x
commutator because it'll be using this
interpretation function gives it a set
of boxes to interpret as and those will
be run through make expression and in
fact if we copy that now out to original
program we'll see it's an actual x
commutator ok so it's kind of nice now
we can move on to taking a look at
associations so this is a new feature
this won't be working in your notebooks
but let's talk about lead rivets
so let's give a notation for leader
evidence will use a
this is a template here or as a pattern
as a as a base okay
so we'd like some template box we're
going to call this Ally derivatives
derivative and we don't need the
interpretation function it's just gonna
be the standard one and so which box is
going to display as well it'll display
as these boxes here so we just go here
grab our boxes our output and our
display function here will just be those
boxes and so that that looks well at
least it's got the right output but of
course we haven't substituted these
parameters I could put another parameter
here in T and then I'd go through here
and I normally go in and put this as
this is a number one this is maybe
number it's got the B it's number two
and this is number three like so and now
it changes and of course if I change the
you know saw my other input it feeds
back into my template box of the queue I
change this to you know D and so on it
feeds back through so we can do that
however we could turn around and do
something a little bit different here we
can actually use named keys and
functions now so we can actually call
this X and we can call this something
hash Y and call this something hash t
and so this is now a function that will
take an association so this is a normal
bit of Mathematica and so we give it an
association now and what's our
association that we're gonna put in plug
in here well we're gonna put something
like X goes to you know a Y goes to B
for instance
and he goes to take work W let's say W
okay and so this now this this this
function here applied will give us a new
box structure and as before roll boxes
we can actually take a look at it and so
this this this is built into Mathematica
the handling of these keys which we can
put named keys in working on
associations that's kind of nice so we
can actually name the variables now and
because of course we're plugging in
numbers like you know 3.1 or 4.2 into a
list under function or something you
can't remember which ones labeled and so
we can actually label them kind of not
like this and so here we go and we can
put this as a display function and it
operates instead of on a list of things
it'll operate now on an association and
so now if I go here and I change this
value here you can actually see the
values are changing in the Association
and just like before we can go and we
can grab and inject this on to the style
sheet get our our Styles turn around and
put a inject styles what are we gonna
inject we're gonna inject the leader
rivet --iv and what styles are gonna
look like what it's gonna look like this
display function plug it in there and
now we don't actually need to specify
the display function and our output like
so because right now it's actually on
the style sheet right here at the bottom
because of our inject styles there's a
lead rivet of right there which we just
did okay so now we have this nice sort
of template boxes working and sorry
template boxes here working for lis
derivatives we can add those things and
we can evaluate them we get lead rivet
--iv and we could turn around and build
up a notation as before would make a
make expression we need to be able to
lead rivet is to actually work would go
here grab the lead rivet --iv and so on
plug data in standard form is going to
be equal to of course we'll call this a
be a the t is going to be some set of
boxes which boxes
well these boxes and of course this a
here it needs to be to make boxes of the
a and standard form and likewise this
needs to be make boxes of b
Oh indeed indeed and this of course
should be of T okay and now this will
evaluate in our lead riveted here
of course will look likely derivatives
in though they'll turn around and we can
you know change them and so on and so
these are all working now by
associations and so that that's kind of
nice so this as we look at the template
box for lead derivative we can see some
sort of mapping and variables and it
gives us a little bit more context than
just sort of some sort of slots with
maybe numbers or something else like
that they're entirely equivalent this is
allow us to do other tricky things
coming up but and it'll also work with
you know template slot sequences and
other advanced complex concepts in in
template boxes okay so one of the other
things is missing arguments now if I
evaluate this template box it has no
arguments and so it doesn't know what to
display here of course and if I go in
and I take a look at that I see it
doesn't have any arguments
but if I can enter some arguments here a
and B it's now filled those in so it's
it's a little bit nicer that it can
actually handle some sorts of inputs
that sort of couldn't be for the same
way with lead riveters here we've got
it's got a display function so it knows
how to fill these in a B and C and we
can actually see it's filled in those
particular arguments and its usage okay
so one other thing I'd like to point out
as well is if we have this you know
we're gonna go fill in some arguments
here a B and C with thusly derivative as
I cursor through this it's sometimes
hard to see the extent of where the
template box actually is so there's an
actual option and it's set on this box
and we can actually see where the the
the template is where it begins and
extends and so if we unform at that we
can actually see these template box
options are directly set on this box and
so it's got a editing highlight color
argument highlight color and color for
the actual overall template box and so
we could go here and we can turn around
and style it by going to the option
inspector typing in template box going
here and editing highlight color change
that here to something
fellows and change this one here to
something like that
everything highlight color and now as I
going here and edit it I can actually
see some sort of nice you know maybe you
want to change the colors maybe they're
a bit garish but you can actually sort
of see the extent of the template box
and see which bits are actually the
arguments of the template box and in
fact we could turn around and do the
exact same thing for the notebook here
go here and change the editing highlight
color for all of template boxes
throughout the notebook and so like so
and now as we go back and we take a look
at no I don't know there are binomials
or our commutator here is we as I go
through my commutator I will see it's
highlighted as I go through the multiple
oh I forgot to mention as well of course
template boxes of course can be nested
and any various levels they all work and
we can see stuff and now as I cursor
through I can see well that's I'm inside
the binomial and if I go inside here I'm
inside the legendre P so it's it's kind
of nice and so it'll be useful and
various context it won't be turned on by
default but you can specify it yourself
on national style sheets okay so now
know that we've got to this stage I go
here I turn the selected notebook I will
turn it off or editing highlighting okay
so so since this is a workshop I've had
to go kind of fast to get through all
the various bits of the content one of
the the final examples you've probably
got enough information now to possibly
try and tackle this this problem here so
the template boxes are a bit aside in
the end you'll probably use them
yourself but one example here is that
normally when we have a list of lists it
appears in standard form like a list of
lists in traditional form it appears
like a matrix would like they have the
output of this to be like a matrix and
normal standard form how would we go
about doing it well we're going to have
some kind of make boxes rule for a list
of lists but we've got to have some sort
of correct holding and this is one where
evaluation comes into it I'll just
evaluate that and I'll show you that
when I hit command shift end here and
standard form is I evaluate this I now
get matrices and so it looks like a
matrix it's kind of nice
how does it go about and do this what
would be the rule the the it's going to
be a make boxes rule and it's something
a bit like this so we've got to be a bit
move I don't get this on the bottom of
the screen here so what we'll do here
make boxes if it's on a list something
that matrix q so it's list like we've
got this unev al u ated we need to put
these unev al u ated arounds various
things we're mapping this function and
make box a standard form we're making
sure we're holding it here holding it
there but basically we go we get a
matrix of things we make all the various
arguments and we shove it into a grid
box in the right way and we get this
kind of output here okay so now that
we've seen how the difficulty in doing
all of this with make boxes make
expression rules we'll go back down to
the notation package and so let me just
quit the kernel so you know that I've
got nothing up my sleeve here and we'll
see how the notation package actually
works so right now after and yeah that's
a a 2.1 bug and our development version
which I'm gonna fix here but it's still
working Mathematica doesn't know how to
understand this ring plus and ring-ring
addition ring x so we can turn around
and we can create a notation statement
here or off the palette just here and we
put in the boxes on this side would be
some escape our of b and that's going to
be ring plus of a underscore combat the
underscore and likewise we can make
another rule do the exact same thing
four times and make this ring x and so
this this notation statement basically
says that these boxes should appear as
this sort of internally as this full
form and this full form should appear as
this boxes it goes both ways and if we
evaluate that now and now go back and
evaluate our our expression here our
ring plus and ring x it actually has
exactly the rightful form so this was a
good bit simpler than adding our make
boxes and make expression rules so
what's going on here how does this work
well if we take a look at the internals
of this by going and printing the
notation rules and getting the right
context and basically taking a look at
what goes on underneath it turns out the
notation package
has its own version of make boxes and
make expression which is almost the same
thing now it does some other tricky bits
like parenthesizes and stuff and some
places which are assertive some cooler
bits which you want to know later on but
sometimes people don't want the notation
package to come up they don't want to
load it so you can actually go in and
take a look at what the notation package
produces and copy those refined rules
yourself as you so neat you okay so
let's take a look now at an example of
up and down we can redo this now and
take a look at notation of a up arrow
and make it up of a and okay there we go
okay
and gives us nice warning and the same
with down at B here down arrow and make
that down and now if I type in you know
of a plus down down oh babe plus you
know I don't know that down of C and I
hit command shift n it appears as before
we had and it parses and it has of
course that correct full form as before
okay and so one final thing nice thing
you can actually do is they had input
aliases let's get some space here go
back up here and we're gonna add an
input alias for let's say our commutator
so we'll call it comm for instance
there's no nothing right now for comm so
go here and we add an input alias we
could do it off the palate or add and
put Elias here and so we're going to add
one for calm and it's going to appear
some kind of boxes which boxes do we
want well we go back here and grab those
boxes these ones here say for instance
if a commutator and go down here paste
this in and now put those in its
placeholders placeholders and now if I
enter some escape com escape plus you
know escape com escape I've got a nice
easy way to do this I can you know a b c
d and it'll appear as my commutator of
course because we don't have that make
boxes rule i could go back and re-enter
make boxes rule for commutator z' down
here and now our commentators will
appear and their output as they should
and it has of course all the correct
full form or I could have done simply
the exact same thing and put it in and
and using the notation package again to
get the commutator okay so I'll just
round out this talk and I'll mention
there's this thing called tag boxes
which you can use instead of template
boxes which were used before they're
generally it's being superseded now by
by template boxes which I and it may be
eight years ago now I guess actually for
a presentation here will from a
technology conference and now that sort
of going everywhere which which is grand
but so the tank box is underneath this
before here is you can actually see this
tag box that it has this tag grid and
this actually controls the formatting of
this grid and it'll it'll keep this
formatting so we use it those kinds of
places will use it in plot I maybe
there's a bug on the screen for showing
the the that can let's just do it there
we go
okay so we've got these things we this
placeholders we can actually tab through
fill them in and actually underneath
you'll actually see that those are tag
boxes with placeholders so they're used
there they're also used announced
appearance and so we can actually take a
look at the underlying form here and you
see this is tag box at Bob with this
appearance tag X we could change that to
why for instance and move over it so
they're used in a few places there's an
example here of old-style typesetting
with with like with tag boxes here and
it has certain problems we'll just you
know run this and you know actually take
a look at it you see this Legendre P it
has this rightful form but for instance
you can grab the head by itself it's
sort of disassociated where's the
template box you you can't grab that
it'll it'll grab the whole the whole the
whole expression okay one final thing
I'd like to mention here is base styles
and so in normal in a text editor here
if I if I've got a text editor
you know I enter some text here and then
I make something italic and then I I go
next to it and I start typing it'll pick
up that style and same with style boxes
it'll pick up the
background but sometimes in your design
of notations you don't want that to
actually happen so you can use this
thing here base style and so this is now
attached to just this under script box
right here and now as I type next to it
it doesn't pick up that style so this
base style and default base style are
options to most of our underlying boxes
and one final thing I should actually
mention is our precedence and grouping
for all of these various operators so
for our partial derivatives for instance
the parse the grouping and precedence
and that this whole operator here is
based on its base so that's true for
subscripts and superscripts and sort of
for some other structures it takes the
default rules of Mathematica but you can
change those rules with syntax form
which is a bit advanced I'll also
mention and rounding this out that for
instance some typesetting here in the in
the front end is actually
context-sensitive for instance point
here just type sets as it doesn't do
anything but Lew here has got this set
up so that when we inside graphics
graphics of point will actually be
rendered into a point and so Lu achieves
this by making the make expression rules
context-sensitive for graphics another
interesting irrelevant note is that a
lot of the whole box model that we've
developed in the front end is actually
very similar to CSS the model so from
Neal and me and others you see that the
inheritance of styles is quite similar
to cascading style sheets our margins
and padding's are similar to image
margins and frame margins so it turns
out there's probably some underlying
truth of how you structure these these
things things which is common to these
systems which have been developed
independently and in fact I'd even
suggest it looks kind of interesting if
you're there's other upcoming related
talks Kevin will be talking about is CSS
importer today at 3:30 other related
talks John will be talking about the
state of the front end today at 11:00
the whole team if you're interested in
this will be around on Thursday at 1:00
and of course Liu be talking about
understanding manipulate which is built
up on these underlying technologies
we've got here so we've talked about how
the front end is represented by these
boxes and these talks build on that
so in conclusion to make your notations
actually work what you do is you
enter a structure in 2d typesetting you
type that into Mathematica you unform at
it and then you copy and you fill in a
few bits to get a display function with
with some slots either as numbered slots
or an association you get the style you
put it on the style sheet you create a
make boxes rule and then for bonus
points you create an input alias for the
notation and that's basically what we do
internally and so using this you can
make up your own notations and actually
have a comprehensible notebook that uses
the notations you're used to using in
your fuel to study